[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you've got me saying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be sure to stay tuned for more coverage
here at Gamescom
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the creator of the
game Awards Jeff Keely hello everyone
welcome to Gamescom how you guys doing I
am so thrilled to be here at Gamescom in
Germany I want to welcome everyone
watching around the world you guys
excited for a big week at Gamescom you
know this is so fun because the games
come guys came to me and said hey we
want to put together a little show to
kick off this big week for gaming and I
said you know what let me talk to all
the publishers all the developers and
called everyone up and they said you
know what this is a great idea to come
here just show you guys some of the best
games that are coming out in the next
couple of years and you're gonna see
them here tonight we're gonna see a lot
of gameplay you guys into that all right
we've got some announcements a surprise
surprises for you as well and it's gonna
be a really fun night now games come
this week there are over 1/2 million
people in Cologne and we're all here to
do one thing which is celebrate video
games and we're gonna have a fun week so
we got two hours of stuff let's get
right to it and kick off Gamescom in
style we're gonna start with a guy who
was on inside Xbox just a couple hours
ago please welcome from the collective
Rod Fergusson
hello Ferguson
- so rod gears 5 coming soon for Xbox
right salutely yes coming very very soon
less than three weeks in fact and a lot
of people since e3 last year but waiting
to see something right yeah I mean we
had a plan you know we wanted to talk
about escape and versus in horde which
we've been doing but obviously for me
three people really want to see more
about the campaign so I figured what
better place to show a new campaign
story trailer alright here we go here's
five games come check it out
bow down before the one you serve you're
going to get what
[Music]
and now we need to kill it
I need you to think about what you saw
that vision every detail 16 external
camera 15 competent Dermot they're here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's nice to be able to show more of the
game it's awesome no you guys have been
doing such an amazing job on this so
tell us a bit about the campaign there
yeah so it's basically a two sided
stories so it's there's one part of the
story is the war returning to Sarah
you know gears for is a little bit about
three people lost in the woods finding
the monsters and now the monsters are
here and they're pissed off right and so
we have to tell that side of the story
and then the other part is really what's
going on inside of Kate's head and
what's her journey so those two stories
coming together probably the best gears
game we've ever made
looks truly epic 60 frames per second or
case 60 frames in campaign on Xbox one X
so it's amazing yeah looks absolutely
incredible all right well let's turn to
something you just announced couple
hours ago on inside Xbox which is horde
tell us about that yeah we wanted to
talk about the new horde so basically
ultimate abilities are the new thing in
the board so every character has their
own unique ability you can do so it kind
of changes up your playstyle and
everybody plays differently things like
Kate can go invisible
you know JT can bring down airstrikes
and so it's in it's per character it's
not for a role so and even engineers
will each have their own ability and
then we also have power tops so there's
new things for powers the economy and
horde and now every 10 waves a new power
top appears you have to decide do we go
expand our base in capture it or do we
just stay in defend and then Jack is a
playable character and so Jack is sort
of a new feature for us that is kind of
an accessible way to play because you
don't take cover or you don't pixel hunt
it's either he's alert taking over
obviously yeah his ultimate is awesome
it's called hijack that we love puns and
basically you shoot a dart into an enemy
and then you possess them and take them
over so you're going up against a scion
with a boom shot hijack them and now
you're a scion with a boom shot and you
get to destroy the enemies with that
looks so cool and Jack as I understand
is also going to be playable in campaign
that's
yeah so we're at a three player co-op
split-screen on the couch as well not
just online yeah and so Jack is the
third player or it can be your second
however but one of the three is Jack and
in like I said it's a great way for
people who don't Nick can't wall bounce
don't know how to take cover that kind
of stuff is like if you want to
introduce somebody to gears getting the
play is Jack the ultimate support friend
who comes around and can heal you can
make you invisible can go find weapons
for you like he's awesome
okay and also you announced back to
horde there's a crossover between Halo
and Gears coming yeah well we figured
Terminator dark fate is not enough you
know Sarah Connor and t100 is great but
what if we Halo Reach coming to the
Master Chief collection we figured why
not have Halo Reach come to Gears of War
so we've got cod in a meal and the
original cast members like brought him
back from 10 years and said back in the
studio you go we need this you know and
so there will playable and horde
playable escape label and vs. so you get
if you have the Ultimate Edition or in
an ultimate game pass you get them plus
all they're customizable alright well I
know the game is here at Gamescom of
course and fans don't have to wait long
to play it either I know and in select
stores in North America you can actually
go to your local Microsoft store and
play horde this week yeah September 6
for ultimate for early access September
10th for regular and you know a little
like Gears pop is out this Thursday so
if you want to get gear sooner and in
your pocket it's out there all things
gears well speaking of gears I want to
congratulate you because we're
announcing tonight that Gears 5 won the
gamescom award for best xbox game great
stuff and we don't the wait long to play
it as I said come in early September for
Xbox and PC coming up really fast and I
can't wait to see everybody online
playing awesome right I appreciate you
making it all the way here from
Vancouver you guys are just finishing up
the game and thanks for coming to your
first ever game skyfirst Gamescom so in
my first time in cologne it's been
amazing the people are amazing and the
fans are awesome so having a great time
awesome all right Rod Fergusson
by gosh and gears five thanks rod
alright once a game you know about but
tonight we do have a couple surprises
for you with brand new things that
haven't leaked anywhere and we always
love to surprise people so take a look
at this announcement of something brand
new
[Music]
[Music]
that's right the classic Comanche is
coming back from THQ Nordic I've loved
playing this game when I was a kid on PC
novalogic voxels and I'm here with Kirk
from nuclear cuz you're the guys that
are bringing this to life right yeah we
did actually great great to be here good
seeing you tonight it's great to see so
tell us a bit about this game how did
this come about you guys getting
involved with this well actually two
years ago during games come we came up
with an idea and approach to it keeps
you know tears cannot ik yeah the cool
guys and said we have an idea how to get
it back to life in the 21st century and
I like the idea and so here we are okay
so and this is a it's a team based
online yeah yeah that's how we roll
basically because we have done a lot of
stuff in the past multiplayer wise yeah
and so yeah but you'll see some live
footage later on so that's right because
we're not just CG trailers we've got
real gameplay for you guys last time and
you want fans to be a part of making
this game right absolutely because
everybody loves helicopters they kick
ass they go in can hi somewhere and then
shoot somebody
so yeah that's alright well let's take a
look at the first gameplay from Comanche
right but you can join us as well
development yes you for this year we go
into alpha and beta and in the beginning
of next year we go into early access so
sign up for the game okay check it out
here it is the first gameplay of
Comanche see him
if piloting a helicopter and a shooter
any fun yes Virginia it is and there's a
game exactly for that
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
Comanche sign up now that's not all THQ
Nordic as they got some more drones for
you check this out
[Music]
all right announced last week was need
for speed heat from EA and everyone's
been saying when do we get to see real
gameplay of it well tonight's the night
please welcome from EA Riley Cooper come
on up ma'am how you doing
all right so need for speed heat we saw
the announcement last week tell us a bit
about this game how is it new or
different for Need for Speed well you
know it focuses on the core experience
of street racing and modified cars at
night with cops into this we've added
sanction racing by day to keep that
experience fresh and help explain why
all these racers are in town all right
sounds pretty cool
we want to see you guys want to see the
gameplay how we do the honors Riley
let's see let's check it out Need for
Speed Heat
welcome to Palm City a fresh world with
new customizations and the return of
cops make Palm City and urban oasis for
those who burn fast and live by their
own words the daytime off is sanctioned
racing events through the speed hunters
show they compete and score Bank with
each new
then use the rewards to tweak your car's
performance and visual customization
cops patrol the streets during the day
but they play by the rules
finding you for speeding and limiting
your progress using controlled moves to
slow you down roam the open-world nab
challenges and collectables as much time
here as you like when you ready switch
into night build your rep by competing
an illicit street races the more you win
the more you keep will rise in the more
rep your game and all the eyes on you
comes with the price tops are on another
level at night and you'll become a
target as your heat level increases as
he gets hired they'll ratchet up their
efforts to stop
leashing helicopters and rhinos take you
down we've coordinated efforts that
adapt to the situation push it too far
and they won't hold back and your car
can only take so much damage so be sure
to make it to a hideout or the garage
without getting busted otherwise you'll
lose everything you've risked step into
your garage where you can tune your
setup to your life take a car and make
it your own we've replaced the speed
cards from payback
you can now unlock parts by building up
rep at night use the bait you've earned
during the day to level up your ride
almost every car can be transformed into
a custom with the revamp material editor
adds a dynamic range of style
combinations while the new exhaust
tuning system did you ride a barque to
go with this bike
man go beyond the car craft and create
your own unique avatar to represent your
style in Palm City
for the first time ever a need for speed
you can now customize your favorite
rides through an app download need for
speed heat studio today for an early
acces into car customization with weekly
car drops a full line of custom parts
and a rap editor you can now build your
custom ride and connect your account to
push it directly into the game get the
app and show off your Need for Speed
style today all Drive will be available
at lunch crew up with your friends but
let us pair you up with others so you
never ride alone you Cruise rides will
be displayed in your garage
you're always up to speed with the
latest creations leaderboards and
challenges are tightly connected to the
crew so push each other to be the best
and get a one up on the wall every days
danger every race means risk now the
chance to lose everything you've worked
for or
being something more
turn the key burn all limits
[Applause]
all right so I saw heaps to do there
that and I can basically build my car
now in advance of the games I how it
works that's right heat studio is an
awesome app you can have access to full
visual customization of most of the cars
in our car list when you've done your
designs you can push them to the need
for speed heat the full game when it
launches November 8th worldwide ok and
heat studio when is that coming out it's
available in most territories on iOS
worldwide on Android right now right now
I said right now there you go that's
gonna make the real alright
Beaufort Street heats you so you can
download that Android and iOS and check
it out all right well that's very cool
Need for Speed oh there's the QR code by
the way if you guys want to snap it
right now grab the app there cool need
for speed heat coming in November thanks
very much for I'll I appreciate you
hanging out thanks for thanks Riley for
me I appreciate it ride
alright we got some more announcements
to make for you now this is one that
again another big surprise for everyone
check it out another world premiere
right here for the first time at
Gamescom Opening Night Live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kerbal space program to come in next
year all right well we still have some
more announcements to go and we're gonna
go right into the next one here check
this out for the first time here at
Gamescom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
little nightmares - how you doing I'm
all right thanks yeah did you get this
shirt on did you do that during the
trailer wearing this all day oh my god
alright well hopefully add a jacket or
something don't spoil any announcements
all right well anyways little nightmares
- the first game was I mean beautiful
what we saw there again in engine
footage from the game for you guys to do
a sequel what where did you want to take
it seems like there's a new character
right yeah it's a new character called
mono that the you'll be playing as six
is there as well so but you'll be
playing as mono and you but the pair of
you are going to a place called the
signal tower which is the the center of
the whole story I mean this is you know
beautiful platforming just incredible
graphics with unreal and what you guys
have put together there and I noticed
mate weapons now we're gonna have some
combat kitchen utensils okay so just
gonna be a little bit is it even
darkroom is it gonna be is there combat
a big part of this game it's it's a part
of the game it's just another part of
the balance really a mini you're never
really gonna be Rambo in our kind of
game so but you can try your best to
stay safe yeah well it looks absolutely
incredible such a cool announcement was
it clear you always wanted to go ready
to do a sequel for this thing we always
wanted to yeah we also had to kind of
convince people that we weren't ever
gonna make another one so you could have
a nice surprise like this but now we've
got you know as you can see from from
the trailer
you're outside now so you know you're
not free but you are outside and so
there's like places like the wilderness
like an abandoned Shack and then we've
got these sadistic teachers and hunter
and label combat looks incredible we
can't wait to see more of it and you'll
have I'm sure more to share at Gamescom
and in the months ahead yeah absolutely
all right well what do you guys think it
out little nightmares - announced right
here at Gamescom there's so much other
stuff going on at Gamescom in the days
ahead and I Jim's gonna have a live
studio where they'll be doing tons of
coverage and joining me now to talk
about the gamescom
Awards and all the things that are
happening this week with awarding great
games is Sidney Goodman from IGN Sydney
take it away well thank you Jeff with me
is none other than Mark Achilli creative
director at Media Molecule mark you and
your team won best original game and
best Sony PlayStation 4 game for dreams
congratulations that's that's fantastic
I'm very happy I'm sure that they are
team will be very happy about that and
I'm just relieved actually that we've
managed to get this far because it's
been a long road so I should probably
say thank you to Sony for letting us
take so long to get here and and really
importantly I want to thank the
community actually who are obviously the
lifeblood of dreams and they've blown us
away blinding us away constantly so
thank you
speaking of community
have been in early access since April
how has it been seeing players create
and explore and dreams oh it's um it's
humbling because there's just so much
talent out there waiting to break into
this industry you know so it's some yeah
it's just it's really exciting watching
people get better and better
day-by-day there's already some
superstars in the community so yeah it's
just gonna get better
awesome well congratulations again and
back to you Jeff Thank You Sydney and
congratulations to the molecules such a
great game at some powering creators
around the world alright now our next
game is one that has been announced but
everyone's been wanting to see game play
on it well tonight we got the first game
play for you predator hunting grounds
from ill phonic and playstation check
this out for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
got moving in the trees
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go your first liquor predator
I'm here with Charles from ill phonic to
talk about this so you guys did Friday
to the 13th yes sir how do you get go
from there to predator well we were just
kind of sitting around and someone
decided to throw out the idea and we
really didn't even have to think about
it or brainstorm it we all just knew
instantly what the game was so it
totally made sense you had to pit you to
get the license you have to pictured I
guess yeah once went to Fox and then
Sony after and and here we are today so
it's pretty amazing all right let's
bring a good luck but it looks really
cool now this is it's multiplayer which
is something big you know yeah
PlayStation it's making a new
multiplayer game and this is obviously
for v1 right yeah it's predator yeah for
fire team members and they're going
through doing missions kind of similar
to the 87 film and then yeah the the
Predators been hunting the fire team so
it's kind of a bit of a hunt becomes
hunt a type moments so yeah
and between obviously gotta balance it
out so it's fun to be on the team or the
predator but tell us about that balance
oh yeah so we're you know it's always
something where we're doing kind of
until the finish line but it's it's
really fun to play both as the predator
or the fire team so right now there's
just a ton of competition in the office
so we have we have a lot of fun with it
awesome I know it's it's sort of early
alpha so you guys are here at Gamescom
show it to media and come in next year
yeah pre-alpha and sometime next year
for sure all right predator hunting
grounds it's one to watch thanks so much
for popping by Charles thanks for having
me awesome great all right well now
we're gonna take a look at a game that
has an expansion coming out in September
monster hunter check this out for the
first time
you hear that what is that
monsters displaying disturbing behavior
some songs miss having an incredible
effect on other life in a new world
you're going to need his help that elder
dragon is going to be a problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Kenneth's ready to fire orders sir
only one respond to spell kana before we
can't fail here
[Music]
[Applause]
at Jaeger we innovate we take risks we
strive to create games you've never
played before
this time it's self-published it's
without compromise its PvE it's PvP it's
a new genre
welcome to the cycle
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I'm here with Jonathan talking
about the cycle so this is P VP ve a
competitive quest shooter break that
down for us how does that actually play
out and plays are pretty interesting
yeah so the mix of PvE and PvP that we
have I don't think it's really been done
like this before so the game is kind of
it's not a cookie cutter game it's it's
really quite different and I think that
the way you can play it you can play it
with PAC team right so you never know
quite know if you're gonna want to shoot
the person that you see you're an active
any time I guess any time yeah but it's
a game that you kind of have to play to
get and
you can is on an epic game store yeah
it's a free download and yeah try it out
let's know what you think awesome and
you guys are doing this independently
which you guys have done lots of games
for lots of publishers before ever
you're just kind of striking it
independently why did you want to do it
that way we're taking quite a lot of
risk with this item to be honest it's
quite innovative and that's not really
for everyone so and we after 20 years I
mean the Eggers been around for 20 years
so we really just had to go for it at
some point so I'm super happy the visa
company had the courage to do it and big
shout out to epic for the support and
their courage as well because it
wouldn't be impossible without their
help lots of cool German game developers
on States tonight as well which is
really cool so awesome well great to
have you here congratu
we will check that out of the epic game
store and now we're gonna take a look at
a new trailer the next episode of life
is strange - episode 4 is coming out
this week and we've got the first look
at the trailer check it out
[Music]
I keep having these nightmares since I
came out of the coma nowhere to go what
do I do now
[Music]
I'm so different now I don't even
recognize myself remember you got to do
this four times a day
I won't forget I'd let everybody down my
boss Daniel where would he hide out we
have a lot of people looking for your
brother this is well for how long it's
been over two months the bureau put his
profile out over four states
you might spend the rest of your life in
prison where you can talk to me we gotta
be careful now how would I even find him
is the whole world out to get me
nobody will stop me
I'm not afraid
I want to help my brother that's all I
can think about
Shawn
alright guys well we're watching I just
got a text
guess who just arrived in the building
today Okajima is here everybody a little
bit later but we do have some desk
rounding for you alright but right now
we're gonna get to another new game
announcement sega and amplitude are
teaming up to introduce a brand new
historical turn-based strategy game what
if you could rework right and reimagine
the entire history of humankind
check out this world premiere PEGI 12
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right now it is time for Borderlands
3 you guys ready all right please
welcome from gearbox Paul say Jeff how
are you I'm doing pretty well you've
been travelling around the world there's
much borderland stuff going on but we
help the way much longer for this coming
in September September 13th so let's
talk Borderlands 3 first of all the
campaign until last week a lot of
previews went up influencers press got
to play it so we got a little footage of
campaign we're gonna talk about first
before we get to talking about the
endgame which we're very excited about
but tell us a bit about the campaign and
sort of what you guys have shared
recently on Borderlands 3 all right so
we showed off about four hours of just
the beginning gameplay where you start
on Pandora and then we moved on to Eden
six which is a new planet we've never
showed out before and we tell this kind
of heartwarming story of two ai's who
fall out of love and one AI who's a
jilted lover takes and shoves the other
AI just straight up into a pink plush
bear who is voiced by none other than
the charisma deck ice-t there you go
ice-t all right in for Larry of course
right now you've got obviously amazing
characters playable flack I mean people
are super excited about what you've
shown in kind of on campaign and the
thing though that everyone want is
always curious now I know it's kind of
silly to be talking about the end game
before the game season out but folks
want to know you know what's the
challenge what you know what what can
you tell us about the end game for
Borderlands 3 alright so all this week
and probably next week and then few more
weeks we're gonna be talking about
endgame yeah first two things we're
gonna talk about the first one is called
a circle of slaughter okay bring the
slaughter from Borderlands yep right and
it's just just wave after wave survival
mechanic of fighting off enemies and the
cool thing about this is that you know
the more you survive the better your
rewards are and there's more though
right there is more
so we're announcing something called
proving ground okay okay proving ground
starts off with the yridians right we're
showing off you know a little bit of the
proving grounds here and the nice thing
is you have to go throughout the game
and discover yridian writing this is
this ancient alien race and then you
find the coordinates to plant it so once
you kind of decipher all these things
and then you find out that you can take
a mission from this iridium that you see
here and the mission has different
objectives in it right so it's got one
which is kill everything because
Borderlands and then it's got optional
objectives like don't die all right do
it within a certain amount of time a
certain thing so you can see all that
yeah yeah you can see the optional
objectives right here and then the nice
thing about the optional objectives is
that if you do those optional objectives
at the end we have a chest and the loot
gets better the how the optional
objectives play out so if you're really
good you'll get the best loot in the
game super or playable obvious if people
decay it's all about replayability at
this point yeah awesome well that's
amazing it's so time-based obviously
going through there with you and my
friends and having an amazing time so
this obviously the proving grounds this
is one map are there multiple proving
grounds obviously yeah there's about
seven different proving grounds
scattered throughout the game I'm
actually sorry I said in seven to mid
six but you know it works I'm sure
they'll be more down the road right
that's all right so that's and there's
I'm sure there's probably even more
in-game or there's all sorts of in-game
you know again like I said we're gonna
talk about it more we have something
called Guardian rank which is if you
play Borderlands 2 it's like badass rank
2.0 we're talking a lot about that so
yeah a lot of stuff coming up all right
well we don't have to wait long for
Borderlands 3 but it's so awesome to see
proving grounds and when can we check it
out well you will be able to check it
out on Friday the 13th that's September
13th 2019 I hope everybody is there oh
yeah and I'm sure you're gonna have it
playable here at Gamescom so ever it'll
be Jeff's now right all right
Borderlands 3 the guys from gearbox ball
thing
get off games come with us really
appreciate it all right so now we've got
a cool new game to show you guys and
this comes from a German studio and
sometimes we get pitched indie games for
Game Awards even games come and
sometimes we get trailers just blow me
away and this is a game that you may not
have heard of before from a studio that
you may not know about but take a look
at this I was really impressed with this
trailer so we're so proud to announce
this brand-new independent game made
here in Germany on opening night live
check this out let me know what you
think I was really impressed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so stranger
what brings you to this no-man's land
there are far more interesting places to
visit take toussant sunny valleys peace
quiet
why
Oh Gallagher
friendly nature breathtaking landscapes
kind [ __ ] welcoming of travellers I
wake you'd have a much better time there
another grant that's another beast
Italian
merchants taverns quent horse races who
knows maybe even true love tell me why
Vallon because here's where my journey
begins
[Applause]
all right there you go witcher 3 switch
announced october 15th
that's the announcement of the release
date for that now we're gonna talk about
FIFA 20 and joining me from EA to talk
about FIFA 20 is Matt Turner for me a
Matt come on out good to see you
so FIFA 20 kind of a big deal especially
over here everyone loves FIFA tell us a
bit about the new Volta what is Volta in
FIFA 20 yeah well Volta football is
really all about
celebrating something that our fans have
been asking for I mean we've been honing
a deep and authentic experience for the
11 the 11 game for a long time you know
bringing you your favorite squads and
clubs and players and stadiums but we
understand that for millions of people
all over the world their stadiums or
streets their cages their courts indulge
the spaces where they can express
themselves have been their creativity to
the game and sometimes even influence
how special game is played so we really
said about creating a fresh and deep and
authentic experience with the street
football flavor and bringing that
creativity and style to the game we have
a refined gameplay experience we have a
brand new customization experience we
really choose which a character looks
like and how they play and how they what
they wear on the court and with all the
ways you can play both the football with
a volta story included if you can see
here for the very first time in a minute
that authenticity and that depth of the
real-life street football experience is
what you're gonna see all over volta
football in FIFA 20 and I know we saw in
the trailer that we're going kind of
around the world we're gonna Eiffel
Tower or other places yeah yeah yeah
that's right so you're gonna create your
eternity to get to test your mettle
against some real legends of street
football and then you're gonna create
your squad and triangle
they're in recruit your your best team
to Tran take a shot at the most
prestigious award in street football
which is the volta won championships
hosted in one of those areas but you're
gonna play in 17 locations across five
continents so Tokyo rooftop the shadow
of Table Mountain shadow of the Eiffel
Tower
you know overlooking the the New York
skyline so all these locations are brand
new and really fresh and unique to see
420 awesome all right well you brought a
clip for the first time a premier clip
from the story mode what are we gonna
see yeah well you're gonna get to you
know create your avatar and really see
how they look at how they play on a
court and obviously spend a lot of time
on a pitch but you're also gonna get to
experience volta football through the
story play in tournaments like the
adidas tango league and one of our
legends kotero tokuda is gonna give you
a little taste of his world championship
winning routine in Tokyo and like any
adventure you're gonna make some friends
along the way and maybe a few enemies
too at the same time all right well
let's take a look at a premier clip from
FIFA 20 volt uh coming in September
right yeah you wanna check it out
Gamescom right now you can if you want
to get it you're early hands on it it's
going to be on EA access and origin
access on September 19th and for the
rest of the world on September 27th
awesome all right let's check it out
FIFA 20 world premiere clip from bolts a
story thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow look at you yeah I guess you took
the hard road how me too
you think we'd learn no I'm the name of
progress right
they say there's always something better
burn the old bring in the new no how'd
that work out risk their whole future
and we trusted nine and that we fight
them any way we can
for what's left of humanity
[Music]
I'm sorry where you do have in a moment
I can leave you all be what the graph
cycle I'm a pilot it's called a
pre-flight inspection
[Applause]
what you guys think of that looks pretty
cool right we got Marcus from v1 here
Marcus this is so cool that
disintegration is real you showed the
real gameplay there are you and I first
started talking about this game I think
like 5 years ago and you're just a
couple people's right you're talking
about the first game Awards of 2014
really may well kickstart this and here
we are five years later you've got a
bigger team now right we do we have a we
started out with three yes and now we
have a small team of 30 people at v1 in
the Seattle area doing that back out in
the Pacific Northwest yes well you're
known for doing some cool things out
there Pacific Northwest with certainly
you know co-creator halo Master Chief
and this is something brand-new tell us
about this new character that you're all
right we've got a new character we're
playing his name is Romer he's trained
grab cycle pilot it's one of these
vehicles that you saw flying in the game
yeah it's a game pretty much unlike
anything you've ever played before and
you're doing campaign and multiplayer
for that is true we have a story a full
single-player story campaign as well as
a huge multiplayer component to it as
well well let's talk about some of the
gameplay we saw there because people you
know know sort of you know first-person
action games and tell us about the style
of gameplay and how you're playing there
and explain what people are saying sure
it's saying it's a first-person shooter
with a lot of real-time tactic elements
blended in so you play as a pilot in
this grab cycle vehicle that hovers
above the ground and you have onboard
weapons for offensive and defensive
capability as well as then commanding a
small squad of units on the ground that
each have their own unique ability so
it's your job to use them strategically
a gameplay it's really cool ya know it
looks amazing and it's got that you know
the feel that I think we know we know
and love from you know halo destiny is
sort of an epic world the great music I
mean it's a lot of signatures there but
it's new and different game types all in
my DNA well the fact that you're doing
you know campaign and multiplayer I
think is absolutely amazing with a team
of 30 or something that looks that
thanks yeah we are taking on something
pretty ambitious with a title like
but the 30-person team in Seattle is a
powerhouse of talent of Triple A devs
like myself as well as them a lot of
emerging talent so it's it's a great mix
this is definitely a game to watch 2020
but now you're gonna let people play it
I mean it's here at Gamescom that's
right
we're playing multiplayer on the floor
so we're pretty excited to have a pretty
buddy jump into a 5/5 pretty frenetic
great experience on multiplayer so it's
pretty great I love you guys announced
the game letting people play it right
here at Gamescom it looks phenomenal
good luck with it hoping to see more of
it soon thank you integration Marcus and
v1 all right awesome free camp thanks
Marcus all right now we're going to take
a look at a trailer for Darksiders
Genesis coming out later this year
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back to Gamescom
opening night live now we're gonna move
on to a game that was announced as part
of a google stadia it's a launch title
please welcome Raul Rubio from tequila
works to talk about guilt
yes so this is exciting you guys are you
know a studio that's done a lot of
really interesting new unique projects
this is a stadia exclusive game and
we've got some gameplay so tell us a bit
about why don't you guys want to build
this game what is it well first of all
I'm very happy to be here yes because
this tequila war 10th anniversary yes
yes that's related to the reason why
we're doing this right well two years
ago in fact basically seeing how the
games are evolving and how the way we
build the way we play it changes
actually well we were excited by the
vision of stadia and they sent a team
for well the next step right the thing
is that you look at all games we are
mostly about touching players with the
meaningful stories the things that that
was perfectly aligned with what the
stadium right looking right and well the
result is guilt of latest creation and
as you say stadia screws here yep long
title ok so tell us a bit about the game
I see there's a woman girl who's walking
around with a flashlight what is she
trying to do she's certainly for a
sister right well yeah as you can see
guilty say is mounted tale yes Santa
territory touching deep and dark things
like childhood fears more important
bullying so you are sally sally's this
little
seeker rapping battle booth is an old
mining town in Maine and the thing is
that her life is not easy and it got
even worse looking for Emily mm okay
somehow chase it by bullies he ended up
drag it in this strange new world and in
really unnatural place with all your
fears Mainers take shape in a week a
very real way so that means that well
the monsters are in fact physical
manifestations of our own terrors and
traumas like apprehension to strangers
or the paranoia of everyone we sprain
around you revealing your deepest
secrets actually bystander standing
there doing nothing in my helplessness
yes so this is what we define as
delicate power that basically is Sally's
journey embarking to save Emily at the
same time trying to understand the
world's running here and you're
obviously defeating these monsters with
this this fly it rains a little bit uh
it's not something but Alan Wake we're
sort of like the light to take things
down how it tell us about how you play
that's correct
guilty son adventure narrative adventure
that means that we are blending elements
like exploration stealth muscles you
have a lot of tools at your disposal in
this case for example
well the flashlight is your beckoning to
drag man so business is what you need to
find your way the thing is that these
monsters can happily are very sensible
to sound and light they can see you if
you use the flashlight in fact you are
exposing yourself it's a way to face
your fears I mean yes some monsters are
quite thin skinned in fat when exposed
under the light of truth you can say it
that way well they turn powerless right
they disappear not only that you can
actually build the strategies like
throwing a can for example to destroy an
enemy or even using the light shaft for
the flashlight looks like you've got
strategy you've got stealth and all this
in the game and it's coming out for
launch right it's coming from lounge
this November this November we hope to
utterly show ceremonious getting ready
yeah dealing with the topic so delegate
and in a meaningful respectful way is in
fact or way to challenge the audience
well that's the ambition of guilt Wow
okay very deep and looks cool that you
guys are doing it for for stadia so
tequila works great to see here oh look
for anything what's next well Ruby out
tequila works fantastic all right well
thanks very much Roland now we are gonna
head on over to the lovely Sidney
Goodman from IGN Sydney what's up well
hello Jeff again I am here with Celia
from Nintendo silly you and your team
won best Nintendo switch game for the
legend of zelda links awakening
congratulations how are you feeling I'm
so excited
yes actually actually I'm very happy
that one of the most beloved games of
The Legend of Zelda series won this
award and a few weeks ago we asked fans
to send us fan art and received within
two and a half weeks four hundred and
fifty letters emails pictures sculptures
miniatures even a lamp and it's really
amazing and you can see here that the
love that Nintendo puts into these games
the laughter detail comes back right to
them
that's amazing I love that a lamp what
creativity so you mention it that Link's
Awakening is just such a beloved Zelda
game I mean its iconic how has it been
being on the team that's working on my
game yeah unfortunately I'm not part of
the development team but I read an
interview from a Muslim and he said they
always want to keep the heart of the
game but on the other hand they always
want to induce some introduce something
new that's the reason why we see here
there's beautiful graphics which like a
miniature world and another new thing is
the dungeon chamber which is super
exciting for players because here they
get the chance to arrange chambers the
way they want it yes so I think even for
players who played it 26 years ago they
now find something new in this new game
well congratulations again Celia I know
I am NOT alone when I say it cannot wait
to get my hands on that and back to you
Jeff fantastic all right thank you very
much a big congratulations to Nintendo
for that and now we're gonna move on to
the world of destiny to any destiny
players out there
all right well please welcome Scott
Taylor and Wendy weight from bungee
hi guys how's it going Jeff Keely things
are going well you guys are very well
branded here come on up so let's talk
about destiny - first of all the newly
independent Bungie it's so cool that you
guys are releasing this on your own now
and as your shirt says shadow keep is
coming October 1 so we're going back to
the moon but tell us a bit about what we
can expect from this expansion
yeah well shadow keep is our new
expansion like you said come out October
1st it involves the return of a
character we haven't seen in a while
Eris morn I one of the beloved
characters from destiny 1 now Eris has
gone on looking around in the moon and
from destiny 1 also and has discovered
something horrible that is unleashed
nightmares for all guardians to come
back and battle so it's the moon but
it's totally transformed by the hive
there's some new spaces that you've
never seen before
and then there's spaces that you think
look familiar but have been totally
totally reimagined Wow now you guys are
also changing kind of the business of
destiny a little bit and how you're
approaching it you know free-to-play and
obviously you know first light to be
able to be able to jump in tell us a bit
about that and how that's going to
change or affect the game yeah new light
is definitely the best time to start
destiny not only because it's free to
download but because the player very
quickly is gonna unlock the game so if
you want to jump in and play campaigns
no problem we got you covered if you
want a fire team-up jump in the crucible
jump in a gambit play co-op strikes it's
all available right off the bat
Wow very cool then crossing yes you can
play those platform 1 yeah that's
awesome yeah cross save coming online
which everyone's excited about and you
know Armour 2.0 there's so much in this
game which everyone wants to know about
but tonight I know you guys prepared a
little bit of news for folks on the
season that's starting of the undying so
who's who's dead that needs to come back
to life well I'm very lucky because I
get to work on one of the teams that
focuses on CS
means we're keeping destiny fresh all
the time it's always a great time to
jump in and this fall what your
guardians are going to the moon to
confront nightmares the vex are bringing
the fight to us okay the backs well
let's check it out what you guys have a
little a little story trailer here to
set it up right yes we do
awesome right well let's check it out a
brand new trailer for destiny - shadow
keep from Bungie we appreciate them
putting this together check it out
[Music]
we say that the black garden is the
birthplace of the vex
but it was not the beginning
it was the reason
the life in the garden called out a
question
the VEX are the answer
they will do anything to protect the
garden
in these things there is symmetry
the gateways have opened
the VEX are coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right some announce what's there
from the epic game store about new
titles joining that family and I'm here
with Jeff from Wizards of the coast and
max who's a big magic player he's we're
gonna talk about MTG arena which is
joining the the epic family right that
is true it is indeed Magic has been part
of players lives for about 25 years all
around the world and since we started
open beta from Magic the Gathering arena
we've had millions of people joined us
and as we expand the game we think the
next best place for the game is to be
part of the epic game store which in be
coming this winter okay
so coming this winter to epic game store
and Max you're a big magic player
streaming playing it what do you like
about MTG arena I think the best part
for me was playing draft during the
stream because there's Twitter on where
your viewers or what let your viewers
life vote on which cards to pick a very
interactive a lot of fun and yeah I'm
still trying off-camera a lot of MTG
arena yeah alright so we don't have to
wait long coming this will mean this
winter yeah very very soon MTG arena all
right we'll check it down the epic game
start thanks guys alright well now we've
got another announcement for you guys
and this ties to a PlayStation game by
the way I know if you guys heard the
news as we were here Sony announced that
they actually bought insomniac so check
your Twitter after but that just got
breaking news during our show but
speaking of PlayStation we've got
another trailer world premiere from
Playstation check this out
nice I'm Sergeant Blake it's extremely
likely whoever killed your father killed
mr. Jarrah is there anything I can do to
help
something going on here I need to find
out what it is
there's an intruder a Delfy house I'm
going why you followed me
let me go
I know what I saw
I know it's real
my god the players
[Applause]
there you go with the shadow drop I'm
here with Jack for flavor works at Holly
the star of Erica great to have you here
at Gamescom welcome so this is a cool
surprise because Erica we hadn't seen
for a while and then everyone's
wondering what's going on and here it is
with the trailer and out tonight so
first of all let me kick off with u-haul
I tell us a bit about Erica the
character that you play Erica is a
little bit of an enigma she's a girl
who's had this incredibly traumatic
childhood experience and her life and
it's shrouded in mystery and so when you
meet her and you join her on her journey
then you sort of decide who she can
trust and you so the mystery with her
and Jack I know you've been you know
people see live action and they wonder
hey is this another you know
Bandersnatch Netflix style thing it's
much more interactive than that can you
kind of explain about you know how
you're treating video yeah we just
wanted to make a game and more open more
so a really innovative narrative game
and so for that we knew we needed really
nuanced performances we've like strong
emotional characters and so holly was
perfect for that more so then we can get
in like you know moco or something I
know mocap yes she was with video it's
always and feels a bit described and
chunky and blocky
and our big thing was we wanted to make
this as interactive as other games where
you're in you're touching the world and
a very tactile way very high fidelity so
we had to build as technology from the
ground up we had to throw away all of
our design rulebook work out how to get
a film culture and a game culture to
work together so the last couple of
years has been us having to throw away
everything we knew and starts again but
we're so happy not just straight kind of
branching a bee path there's much more
interactivity moulded Tamala exactly
there's lots of branching and it's
actually really ambitious branching for
a team of literally six people for the
last couple of years and it completely
changed the way that we had to film this
stuff but it was kind of made of quite
like an intentionally ambiguous and
quite out there so the story so that
around a water-cooler there's that thing
of we've all seen it but from what
perspective did we see it and that was
something that really excited us tell me
about filming this because I'm sure you
had all these different branching past
your character to go in all these
different directions it was crazy it was
such
it was quite a massive challenge because
obviously I've never done anything like
this before and films are quite linear
and yeah I've had all these different
branches to go down and it's quite
emotional for the character it goes to
quite a lot of deep and dark places but
also because of the interactive side it
has this physicality so I had to even
though I was in the surroundings and
it's really me there and so you get out
the nuances of a real-life actor and not
a CGI character yeah it's incredibly
hard and it was absolutely brilliant or
there just knew every avenue of the game
like it was absolutely magic but yes
it's really good performance super cool
and and this is awesome because you can
download it today worldwide on place to
any right off to the show it comes out
999 euros pounds dollars it's been a
labor of love for years so this is
really exciting for us and then you can
play it on the show floor if you're at
Gamescom tomorrow sooo awesome alright
well Jack Holly thank you so much for
coming all the way to Cologne thank you
kick it off Erica I appreciate guys
thanks for coming by
[Applause]
all right well we've got a lot to tell
you about Gamescom this week is we are
just kicking things off tonight on
Monday and if you're watching this or if
you're here won't let you know that you
can also go to Gamescom now which is on
the gamescom dot global website and
that's a way that you can discover games
come all week all the live streams
throughout the week will be available
through this portal to anyone around the
world Gamescom is really trying to bring
the show to fans internationally and
globally even more this year so Gamescom
now you can check out I was want to tell
you some of the other things they're
gonna be happening throughout the week
so IGN is gonna be doing live streams
for the rest of the week from their
studio i gen at Gamescom now and there's
also some other cool things like a know
the game from Ubisoft is going to have a
free it's gonna be free on you play for
the next couple of weeks tide the
gamescom so you can check that out and
it's a cool idea to take the games from
the show floor here and make them
playable to fans at home which is really
really cool but this area is called the
gamescom event arena and there'll be
some great esports tournaments happening
here on the ESL summer championship in
csgo League of Legends will be here
asphalt 9 and there's also something
this is so cool the farming simulator
League has its turn I have to show you
some footage of this but they told me
this I'm like no it just actually
happened and like it's amazing to see
that this is happens here in Europe I
love this so farming simulator League
right to the top of twitch we hope with
all the activities but this is like
actually happening farming simulator
League so you guys know this I guess I
have when I saw this back in the States
and like we have to show this to people
so you guys if you're injured you can
watch the first thing simulator League
live here from Gamescom there is also a
cosplay area an indie village with over
5,000 square meters of indie games and
there are also concerts as well you guys
get a whole week of games come there's a
festival in the city of Cologne this
weekend but speaking of concerts Sydney
from IGN is with one of the acts that's
gonna be performing this week Sydney who
are you with well I am with parson strum
of
on a part you guys are performing tell
us more about it thank you so much I'm
very excited being here yeah a couple of
years ago we were here and we played the
first ever rock concert at Gamescom and
now we're back to play some more heavy
metal and when are you playing we're
playing at the wargaming booth Wednesday
at 9 o'clock
perfect well make sure you check that
out and you also have a collaboration
can you tell us more about that yeah of
course there's a new game coming out
from wargaming and it's a hack and slash
RPG called pagan online and we thought a
game about pagans mythology needed a
Swedish pagan and so we kind of put our
singers skin and but looking better than
he would do in real life and more badass
than you adjusting to real life and you
can have the skin in the game now along
with some legendary weapons amazing well
I can't wait to see it and good luck not
that you need it at your concert and now
it's time to check out some more world
premiere trailers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
fifties men on a Dead Man's Chest
for the rest
[Music]
be honest
[Music]
hey Gamescom 2019 it's Toby and Julian
from the iron harvest team and we are
proud to present you our classic
realtime strategy game iron harvest 1920
plus in iron harvest giant these
apartments were created to support the
people but instead cause trouble chaos
and despair and now it's your turn to
fight back and to learn more about the
three factions in our thrilling
single-player campaign or challenge your
friends and intense multiplayer [ __ ]
in this squad based combat RTS coming to
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC and when
we say PC we say it's on Steam and it
will be across other stores at launch
and if you're alone anyway give us your
high five come to Hall 9 and meet us at
the deep server area and don't forget to
wish list iron harvest on Steam so now
enjoy a new trailer and see you on the
battlefield we were all busy with our
own small lives didn't know what went on
in secret
didn't see the war coming
they said the war would be worn within
months an adventurer promising pride and
other
in the end it would be five years
years of torment and horror like the
world had never seen before
the great war that was supposed to end
all wars is over
while in secret they see this zone for
the next war
[Music]
but this time we're vigilant
[Applause]
Gamescom is in full-swing which means we
have more 2019 games come award winners
let's hear it for best action adventure
game black sad under the skin from aster
gan best action game doom eternal from
ZeniMax best mobile game is battle
chasers night war mobile edition from
handy games best racing game is grid
from Koch media best sports game roller
champions from Ubisoft
best simulation game planet zoo from
frontier best strategy game Desperados 3
from THQ Nordic best family game
concrete genie from Sony best
role-playing game wasteland 3 from Koch
media and best PC game is ghost recon a
break point from Ubisoft now let's hear
it for the winners
there we go
congratulations to all of those Gamescom
Award winner is as Jeff said IGN will be
live all week long and we've got you
covered for all your games comm 2019
needs Gamescom is the biggest gaming
event on earth with over 350,000 fans
attending from all over the world but if
you're not one of them don't worry
because IGN has you covered
starting Tuesday IGN is bringing you a
week of live coverage from hall 7
streaming exclusive demos tons of brand
new gameplay developer interviews and
sights and sounds from the show floor
this is the heart of gaming and it all
starts Tuesday on IGN at Gamescom now
that about does it for me tonight but
like that wonderful video just said we
will be live on IGN all week long thank
you so much Jeff for having me and back
to you thanks SID great to have you with
us congratulations to all the winners
there more words I think coming from the
fans on IGN this weekend
all right now let's turn to the world of
call of duty modern warfare to talk
about all things modern warfare
please welcome Dino from infinity war
you know see you man thanks for making
me to see you thanks for having me
alright so call of duty modern warfare
you're on brand and this is call of duty
modern warfare but it's a reimagine
modern warfare exactly that is the exact
term we used at Infinity Ward is that it
is a reimagining of the modern warfare
franchise so it's still modern warfare
through and through
complete with some familiar characters
as well but the overall narrative and
the single-player storyline are
completely new and fresh and updated to
be relevant and fit in a present-day
okay you guys had the multiplayer reveal
a couple of weeks ago lots of news
around that tell us what's the focus of
mp44 MW this year so first of all we
were just blown away by the reaction
from the fans and the players
our overall goal this year for MP was to
create the ultimate multiplayer
playground so we've got all sorts of
shapes and sizes of experiences we've
got our smaller tighter fast and frantic
2v2 maps we've got our more traditional
6v6 maps and we've also got experiences
on our larger scale maps that are gonna
support upwards of a hundred players Wow
okay and you're also doing cross play as
well right yes we are indeed so we've
actually had a lot of questions from the
community about how cross play works in
a nutshell you'll be able to play
console to console and console to PC so
if you're partying it up on console and
you have a friend NPC that you want to
play with you guys can play together oh
wow okay so across everything it's all
gonna work absolutely
you also had a fun mode that I got to
play back in May at the studio 2v2 gun
fight which is like tell us bit about
but it's like a ton of right it is the
fast pace it is a ton of fun it's fast
its frenetic I actually heard you did
pretty well over there we had a fun time
me and Annie McNamara from Game Informer
took some other drugs I think we compete
against somebody didn't courage are
those guys but those guys are real
Slayers though that's gonna say you held
your own yeah it was it was a fun mode
and I understand that you guys are gonna
be we know what you're doing a beta in
September bus we are and I hear there
might be something before that
absolutely so first of all if you're
here and happened to be at the show you
will be able to play Modern Warfare it's
on the show floor check it out at the
PlayStation booth okay
and so in preparation for our beta where
we get to be able to collect a lot of
feedback from the fans as well as test
cross-play we're doing an early test and
we've partnered with Playstation to have
an open to v2 alpha that's gonna start
this Friday August 23rd okay
this Friday August 23rd and that's
worldwide on PlayStation 4 yes it is
okay we will check it out call of duty
modern warfare alpha and I understand we
got a little little sneak peek of it
right absolutely I brought a trailer
along with me so that people can see
what's coming up all right see all the
maps everything in the Alpha thanks so
much do you know thank you very much
show you modern warfare
[Music]
[Music]
play the Alfa exclusively on ps4 for the
players now you know I spent a lot of
time around game developers during the
final hours of development on their
games and sometimes you just can't do
anything but think about finishing your
game and you can't travel anywhere
you're focused in the studio but now
it's time to introduce a guest to his
only weeks away from finishing his next
title but that didn't stop him from
flying halfway around the world to be
here at Gamescom with us tonight I'm so
honored that he's here you may know who
I'm talking about but take a look at
this
[Applause]
travel to tonight's awards ceremony to
accept any awards gift please enjoy
one and only a day of Gina
[Applause]
such an honor to work with you you're
such a genius he is one of the most
principled loyal and ethical man I have
ever met
I love gay was out of this world
I did love you all from my heart I do
anything
[Music]
Gamescom stranded on your feet
he's here the one and only head
al-khatib ah
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. kijima it is such an honor to have
you with us
I know how hard you've been working to
finish up the game is coho I know gone
everybody okay I returned after five
years to visit games come again it's
great to have you back and ever great
look at the selfies happening I know
this is surrounding this naima oh you
come you know sweetie it's a nice easy
key there hunter game beaucoup now in
the ski the wall - on a high note a
gothic you monster death trending is in
the final really crunch time of
development stage and I shouldn't
actually be here but I really wanted to
meet you all
so I came to Germany which is so amazing
so mr. kijima we know that your as you
said just about finishing up the game
and everyone's very curious the whole
world is curious what you can tell us
about this game and what you want to
share tonight with all of us so what can
you tell us about what you want to
introduce game with a meticulous I know
yes trending is a totally new game it's
an open world game and it's a very very
new and I hope that everyone will like
it
then of course Naomi Conde hartamanda
Tara soakers to humor you had a
character ahsoka is or to talk visit a
tour bus so since it was quite popular
to show a new character a Comic Con
today I would like to I introduce more
new characters today hey let's look at
the first one okay let's take a look at
the first character for mr. kijima
[Music]
[Applause]
even though she can't drink it my body
keeps making you going through the
motions really helps with this organism
what is she she's my daughter and I'm
her mama it's okay
she's only connecting to me it's not
like the other bt's can see it right
you're hooked up
now you know why I can't leave
[Applause]
that was kind of the introductions seen
of mama played by Molly so there are a
lot of characters appear in des trending
and each unique character has like a sub
story from apart from the main story
nakka nakka Changa como anima is an
enumerative so no I'm gonna do a catch
onto his load is an adaptation crusted
it to City maturities so Mama's setting
is that her baby was born unfortunately
on the other side and not in her world
so but however they are still connected
by the umbilical cord so that's why she
can't that's how they kind of exist no
syndicate Santo she no sekai de it's not
this so can i - joey solar collectors so
she's a she has a sad background where
she can't move because her baby is
actually on the other side and she's on
the the real world and they're still
connected that's why she can't move from
that location hi years old i have
another one to see oh okay let's check
it out we got a lot of stuff for you
[Applause]
deadman you there little help okay
remove the body connected to that
incubator good temporary excessive
stresses easily addresses will return
him to his mother's womb mother located
in the capital not City I see you bring
that of course he means still mother
correct
hey still mother who facilitates a
connection between the world of the dead
and the baby and you in turn connect
yourself to a baby granting you the
ability to sense Metis
these thoughts were designed to simulate
the conditions inside a steel mother's
room babies need to believe is there
anyone at all times to function properly
however we can only maintain this
deception for so long which is why we
must periodically update the
environmental data by synchronizing it
with a steel mother via the chiral
Network there the update is in progress
right now the vortices furnaces with the
steel mother in capital not City and
reconfiguring its citizens based on the
latest data returning your baby to the
womb in this manner will temporarily
reduce its stress levels that being
where it technically belongs of course
kid looks happy
now try adjusting lots of thousand
dosage how the toxemia should have said
it much lower for now on you should
remember that ladies are just equipment
try not to get attached each one has
been physically removed from its steel
mother's room a process that renders
them an unpredictable prone to failure
no median record has remained in service
for over a year it may need to be
retired before this expedition is over
and then you say there's no way to keep
my baby alive you must understand there
is still a great deal we don't know our
babies as we expand the cargo net and
recover more pathdata perhaps we'll find
our answers
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that was an introduction of dead
man played by your mo del Toro and also
introduction about the saga we need a
mobility treated mosquito Korea they
take oh no Thomas now you saw the video
explaining what Bibi was about and you
saw that Sam always had this baby in his
pod and I'm wondering what it was about
so that gives a great explanation of it
Beto some Gazzaniga reported a big
invaded Korea
Cochino second tried to coordinate it so
it's again another kind of a sad story
that Sam has with the baby because the
BB is connected to the world of the dead
and that allows the connection between
BB and Sam so that the Sam could see the
BTS the minute some who do not tell baby
Tony baby toe someone who can't get
anymore story no cure that was so you so
you will kind of have this journey with
the baby together and you will have
attachment and and more connection and
that will be the part of the gameplay
Wow well that's pretty amazing to see
the level that you're thinking of the
two worlds everything coming together
it's it's amazing
well mr. kijima I think everyone here is
excited to see characters but I don't
know about you but you wanna see some
gameplay a desk ranek
right understand automotive master I'm
kind of thinking of showing the gameplay
at tokyo game show
Decimus Jeff since it's it's just show
and everyone so excited I would like to
show you just a little bit of it we kind
of a hint to you as well Vicky
told you she was and of course there'll
be a little gameplay that I would like
to show you next but there'll be a kind
of a star that will come out make sure
you catch that star that appears let's
look at it together all right here we go
the first gameplay death stranding
[Applause]
just a little longer
let's get him over
[Applause]
nothing
over here I'm Sam hey
anyone
anybody hear me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how you doing Sam
delivering cargo
[Music]
Hey
Thank You Carly weapons restrictions
lifted
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the voice is different by we are asked
Jeff to appear in our game as a cameo
thank you it was honored to be asked to
be in the game Matthew Mercer actually
does the voice of the characters that I
play in the game and I know they're a
bunch of cameos in the game as well from
from friends of yours tell me a bit
about the gameplay that we got to see
there what do I know it's a new style of
game and you've talked about you know
the Strand John and I think it's very
important for able to see there are a
lot of hints there about the type of
game I can't really say so much but
you're you're gonna play a Sam and
you're gonna have to connect the
fractured cities and people from east to
west and you have to connect and there
are some obstacles in the way like BTS
or terrorists and there are along the
way you'll find people like living alone
like you saw Jeff we call it Preppers
[Music]
main story honking nice there are
actually kind of hiding so some Preppers
don't really have to do with the main
storyline so you might want to find
these Preppers along the way and if you
kind of get connected with them you
might have some good things that they
provide you Tsunade Kondos kamal so no
Jeannie no Mina Sangha it's not a pity
to you so cool so I can't really reveal
too much but when you start to connect
like this in the game with Preppers and
others you will notice that your
was connected to the people worldwide
they come together to the video they
massacred Oh be nice to reaso kakarotto
not good all day so good I asked aki-nee
video Wow a prestige [ __ ] no so in the
video with mr. del Toro
he explained about the baby sometimes
get self poisoned you saw in the
gameplay as well when you kind of fell
the baby is stressed so what you do is
you used PlayStation fours motion
controller sensitive controller and you
kind of like but if you shake fast the
baby will get angry so make sure you
kind of handle with care damn I suck at
all about the urine part it's late
enough to kind of it discuss about that
right my Camaro Massimo somewhat it
misses
so if you're like try to be try to move
the camera and try to see what he's
doing sambal move away so you'll never
see actually what he's doing but and
also there's an option where you cannot
release yourself like that like if
people are new years so don't worry
Norman fans you won't have to be you
know you don't have to worry about that
although I heard is it true that that
also can be a weapon though in the game
no bikini Menotti must she be now go
genius so yes it could be used as a
weapon but also it could kind of it
would be kind of one of the key and
you'll find out later
another secret oh you saw the mushroom
growing so if everyone kind of does it
at the same spot a well you all have
something good later on so what did you
know
well of course that's not the main part
of the game okay the main part is to
connect the world together Wow well I
gotta say it's so amazing to you know
get a little insight into your mind
between those clips and the gameplay
like everyone's trying to piece together
how this all fits together but it's
amazing stuff now I know we have some
photos when I got this it was a couple
years ago when you scan behind you
wouldn't even tell me what we were doing
but you're like come down to San Diego
it said here they put dots on my face
they did the full scan I was there the
same day that Nicholas wooden Reverend
did his scan as well it's almost like I
think September October two years ago
and I know what you're gonna do it that
you're like trust me Jeff I'm like okay
sure and then I find out I'm Luden's fan
right so if you find him in the game and
if you go to him and make the connection
with him he might give you something
good didn't they
Jeff is actually a parent and you could
find him easily so when the game comes
out just look for Jeff
okay well I'm honored to have a little
roll with the kami and there'll be some
other cameos I'm sure as well in this
game yes I can't really say who yet but
there are many people in cameos mr.
kijima thank you so much for coming all
this way to share a little bit more of
deaths training with us what do you guys
think
there's so much there and we don't have
to wait long if you guys are on track
for the game to come out this November
right alright thank you so much yes
that's right and mr. kijima will also be
doing a signing session here at Gamescom
right and that'll be one more thing
sorry Victor Emmanuel Kant inuvik
Arianna briefing no more boost there
you'll see more about like the briefing
the reason why Sam has to do this the
briefing scenes you'll see at the Sony
booth from tomorrow so if you have time
just stop by and if you see that you
understand what you saw today with
trying to find Jeff and things like that
so it will be you'll get to be revealed
more you'll be understanding what we saw
today awesome all right so there's a
briefing scene at the Sony booth mr.
kijima will also be doing a signing and
I can't tell you how much we all
appreciate you coming all the way from
Tokyo just as you're finishing the game
to be here for me to be here for the
fans give it up mr. Kojima
[Applause]
damn Tajima thank you so much my friend
it's always such a pleasure
Aki thank you so much damn Kojima all
right guys well that's gonna do it for
our first-ever Gamescom Opening Night
Live do you guys have fun should we do
this every year all right well I gotta
say it's been a ton of fun putting this
together it's been great to be here in
Europe I want to thank all the
developers I want to thank game and call
Messi for giving us the opportunity to
do this I want to thank a lot of my team
that came all the way over from Los
Angeles to produce this with me we will
see you guys of course this December the
game Awards will be back for our fifth
anniversary live in Los Angeles much
more information coming soon we've got
some pretty cool stuff to show you guys
there's some big new announcements so
stay tuned for that but enjoy Gamescom
guys thank you so much I'm Geoff Keeley
how about great games come and we'll see
you in December at the game all right so
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]